how's gum raspberry spirit pack welcome
back to alien isolation that guy hurts
me sorry
all right we're with this gentleman he's
dick face and we're stuck in this place
with an alien aren't we you have to talk
to him again or what's up it's cool I
here we go
I forgot the emergency override my bad
it's always forget the emergency
override dirty laundry this place kind
of smells - I get it you scratch my ass
I massage yours that's what he wants
isn't he dirty [ __ ] okay
okay I know the alien is gonna come here
I know yeah cool man you're not so cool
as people say you are cool man all right
we need to find his office no shut it
notice
I'm getting pretty good at these there
we go
I love my nails they're so chic
whenever I get them done you look good
man
all right passcode passcode passcode
there we are all right let's check
through his documents there it is yes
god it's like oh hell now I know what it
is
I know exactly what that is
Oh God oh Jesus Christ man hi - hi night
oh god oh god oh god I'm so fancy you
already know okay
okay I'm in the fast lane from manly to
Tokyo he's got that ass so he walks
differently last time he went in there I
assume he wants my ass I like to think
it's a she actually his key card is in
here somewhere we could take this route
and perhaps hide in here yes that would
be the best solution oh god oh god he
opened that door what the fudge cake
this tracker is the worst piece of [ __ ]
I swear to God we call Oh God okay okay
I got him on the tracker now he went
away how the fudge cake am I gonna live
my life this is [ __ ] terrifying man
this is outmost rad unready Kohli oh god
he's close he's close he's close we're
close to the keycard though
I am not oh god oh god oh god he's
coming he's gonna come from there
get me an oh god oh god oh god uh-oh
this is not good for my mental state man
no bueno por por apartment hola todos
loco Pato
okay he's far away that looks like it's
closed
oh [ __ ] all right listen whoa [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I panicked about the code good
job me
good thing I use the flashbang very
useful very useful stuff that way what
what that [ __ ] okay
okay here we are once again my only
friend one-seven-zero
- go go go I'm a hoe I'm a hoe I'm a hoe
I'm a hoe close that star oh god oh god
oh thank Jesus Christ he won't come in
here Willie please
please be kind to my poor soul oh god I
don't trust it
oh he's coming he's coming he's coming I
better hide I better hide
I don't trust anything in life I ain't
taking no chances alright he's in here I
[ __ ] hear him what happened what
happened my [ __ ] autosave sucked my
dick what are you doing
why would I need to autosave a [ __ ]
document I'm not using you Nazi son of a
scumbag Adobe uh-huh what happened we're
still recording it's still good I think
God it paused no big deal he's not gonna
find me I'm scared oh oh well that's
some kinky [ __ ] isn't it so delish what
about the tracking it has to be safe
about now oh boy sure that was fun Oh
[Applause]
[ __ ] sick to my [ __ ] tummy I
bet she must think I'm a [ __ ]
dummy because I just funny [ __ ] think
I'm broke
they check one Roach don't come here
don't come here don't come here
PewDiePie is busy looking for dead
people all right where can I hide I can
hide you there if I'm plot zone don't
you worry don't you worry child there's
this a giant alien that wants to eat
your face dr. mole a morally Oh for
[ __ ] sake I think all right we cool
our [ __ ] Cola
we're [ __ ] cooler than cool ice cool
and that's pretty [ __ ] cool
[ __ ] you
alright [ __ ] you oh god where where
this is where we need to go great
[ __ ] you you're not coming in here [ __ ]
doesn't seem to want to stop anyone okay
all right out of use
what is this I've gone through hell
come on I can still hear that son you
ain't going in here [ __ ] I'll emergency
your ass all day can't be that bad oh we
have microwaves so any bunch of straws
that's good no that's corn flakes
I love complex a frame beep arranged
cheek that's what I said in life a plane
beep
it ain't cheek a frame beep some people
say that I rock hollow a pipe bomb bang
what's with the [ __ ] noise calm down
it was a pipe bomb
chill out maxin relaxin all cool and all
shootin some pipe bomb 29 I was hoping
for a lower number over here alright
let's check it out just for funsies oh
well there was fun party time here I
knew it I knew it
let's search you hello what did you have
an injective keycard
well well how do you do mr. Morrison
what did you do here I see you had a
friend what the fudge is going on down
here
Oh God
nananana we came so far that's close it
can't trust anyone these days
Oh God
high stats on flak name we're not gonna
die here Bruce we're gonna escape and
we're gonna get married one day you're
gonna die in a warm bed slurping on some
[ __ ] kool-aid okay all right you're
gonna run [ __ ] life okay keep going with
the plan we got a plan
we got a plan let's stick to it okay
that door is locked
[ __ ] maybe we can open it yes yes yes
yes yes genius
all right now let's find we need a plan
B in case of [ __ ] goes down run that's
our only plan right now run mother
[ __ ]
run station yes
where's the emergency override Wow okay
now let's get down to the dispensary Oh
whatever you say sweetheart
what do what am I supposed to do though
we did it though good job rose I'm proud
of myself for completing that what if I
don't want to well [ __ ] me cool man I
bet that's not even his real name and
[ __ ] shouldn't be he'd be down here hi
um you know if [ __ ] goes down and I'm
probably gonna die a horrible death say
if you want in you know then what then
we can leave
you probably shouldn't going
oh my [ __ ] god that woman has a great
[ __ ] haircut I have the key card I
don't need him in this [ __ ] Cherie and
I don't have it anymore [ __ ]
bye [ __ ] what a snip of Snapple how
great my little friend came with me
it looks like oh god that's I was hoping
for that it's really really really
[ __ ] hoping it would go the elevator
with me
not that I would just escape life
forever
and a horrible death forever and that's
what I mean Jesus Christ a station my
god I love you I'm serious you're
underrated and hated and castrated let's
be honest here our wait we need to go to
their care floor it's like the game
think I have nothing better to do with
my life ah loot I don't really see up I
can hide in those Oh God
I just want to know where I'm supposed
to go find a trauma kit what the [ __ ] no
no no everyone take it EA really [ __ ]
easy hey mate I have a flashbang and I'm
not afraid of full of bang it if you
know what I'm saying okay a stunned by
time what that [ __ ] [ __ ] it's about
to get oh it's one of these electric
dildos said in my mom told me about
anyway
let's poke some [ __ ] with it I feel
less a pin less lonely now you want to
be poked
that's right well that's what happens
what was that [ __ ] in my eyes out Oh for
[ __ ] sake he's gonna come wait it's
where I think I just wasted like it's
only charged I'm not even kidding how do
we I I don't know how but I made the
game go into window mode that's pretty
impressive all right well it's good to
know when life gives you lemons you
don't put them in your mouth all right I
have one charge on this [ __ ]
got one charge got my mind on my charge
and my charge on my mind
select all right got it and then found a
trauma kit trauma kit they said ah they
must be in here hello and injector we
had deaths that looks very interesting
very Spacey in future don't fight me
mate
and think so alright let me check this
Tabasco low link Frank I did tell you
talk to you I've got a body up here
that's part of martial investigation
female late thirties chest full mmm
interesting activate the cooling system
why not
I want to activate the cooling system
it's light oh we can have to engage the
coolant first my bad now let's forget to
engage the coolant that's my oh god oh
god oh god oh god okay okay
fight me
never sleep pills that sounds great
why did you have to me missing why did
you have to be a [ __ ] all right he's
here let's just keep going we're fine
it's just a game anyway hi guys how's
the cooling going maybe I can cool the
alien that'd be cool yep Oh Sonya and I
was walking on you I'm walking on
sunshine
Wow oh there you are my friend I need
you I'm walking on sunshine oh you could
come from the top better watch out you
better not pound you better not cry I'm
telling you why Santa Clauses come in
daddy girl would get it proud of myself
and the whole YouTube community let's
activate this stable running I feel like
we give away we're focused and very cool
right now what now what now they're all
so cool they're all so [ __ ] cool what
else would you possibly demand of a man
of me like Do You Know Who I am
do you know how lil I'm capable of why
do you do this God um Taylor is Indian
well [ __ ] me and [ __ ] madam know me okay
he's over there now so we're just gonna
go on a little walk in the pink I love
parks and I love walking and I love
talking and I love talking all right
maybe we didn't need something here um
I'm a good hacker luckily so
it should not be a problem err yeah we
don't need that [ __ ] yeah we need vent
axes
hey dr. lingard senior medical officer
should be able to find out where they're
keeping everything in her office oh ow
ow
um well excuse me princess got some [ __ ]
to be doing even where is he
run
totally Berlin I will taste your ass
that's raining oh my god I love nice
picture why not you know what let's go
in the bottle we never win here see with
the Buckhorn girls okay yeah we had to
go up here we could have almost made it
that would have been so epic just don't
look back don't you worry don't you
worry chat
this Heaven's got a plan for you I am so
[ __ ]
so [ __ ] why is that beeping thing doing
doesn't work that well in defense hi
let's find a way to hide alright there
we go you always need a place to hide
because as soon as he finds you you are
[ __ ] a name what what now he's coming
fast ah Martha I see you made it like as
skinny as always and why are we heading
exactly in here all I have looks good
enough for me oh yeah it's injectors
well I don't need those Oh Frank how you
doing
let's check out the computer subasta
link report I have been placed under
arrest with regard zero and ransom C's
instead of operations he he made certain
threats for my career and my
certification I want that on record know
what type of fares IG had encountered
but it had planted something inside yeah
they come out of the belly like that and
make them preggy and make a prig in than
they thought [ __ ] my ass out are you
[ __ ] serious oh my god
oh that's just [ __ ] fine and Danny
isn't it how does he keep doing that
what is the plan here exactly I don't
even get to investigate everything let's
check my favorite computer this doesn't
do much for me I hate to say it hate to
break it out for you mr. glass but
you're not that tough fart oh she's this
[ __ ] ass out my ass jesus [ __ ]
christ how am i live how don't question
it just go with it
shut up skeleton you don't know me
Explorer I don't think this I wouldn't
really say this is time for exploring
mate
now I would not saw Danny loved and what
I excluding another so that right there
they can go for a planned they can go
for [ __ ] I need to go in here I'll catch
you later alligator
I think it saw me they said rope no I
chased you come on tasting I don't
understand alright you can't taste them
got it
see see how fast you're [ __ ] when they
find you it's like I don't even know how
to speak English in emo oh Jesus Christ
that's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up man Oh
God can you stop killing me in horrible
horrible ways that would I would
appreciate that because I'm getting
tired of that no please please please
please should I taste to taste or not to
taste that is the question think he
knows I'm here
oh that nice ass that's thumbnail right
there now go go you [ __ ] hole it's so
sneaky you don't belong here no one
likes you
I hope the door closes in his [ __ ]
back what are those things on the back
so disgusting so nasty
like my god so nasty
god damn freakin boxes flying everywhere
Oh God
alright I think this is a save station
hey Puma how you doing that's a key in
the microwave with you that's
interesting
should probably check that out what's
the fog passcode we don't have that it's
probably on a computer
blueprint to make white [ __ ] it
to 5:05
good job good job on that little little
hacking thing I should be a [ __ ]
hacker while I'm at it I'll have the
Puma and I have their egami
but [ __ ] everything else yeah I just
want to go home all right
I'm so done this is safe
please wait why I don't want to I don't
like waiting what's what are you doing
you're such a [ __ ] you're such a
push-up I'm psychic tired of everyone's
attitude all right I'm the one under
pressure here
literally you know much pressure that
fire is adding to this place I mean I
would be oh oh oh but why didn't you
tell me key card or excuse me when I go
through thank you
ah jeez gents what did they do to you
against it appears your nip I told you
not to pierce your nips it's not I know
it's stylish but it doesn't matter it
looks ridiculous what are you gonna do
to cover that up
you can keep your beer in there that's a
dumb mate that's actually pretty smart
actually now that I think about it
actually man you got a point gents but a
point doesn't get you [ __ ] well I
guess technically wait a human eye out
let's send up Hey
oh no time to play around maybe it was
nice who [ __ ] cares quite more that
can't be an alien Kenny alright never
mind a fan man and then Oh God okay
we're fine right cool I'm cool I'm so
cool everything in life has led up to
this point of me being cool so cool look
how cool I am
alright it looks like we need to go
there but why do I check out the
analysis room well right they always
wanted to see analysis room
I'm let's see how I analyze this and
this that's very good to analyze big fan
of this and licenses in one are they oh
how convenient that you would come here
Joe wait I'm a lap oh no I'm not could
you let me live or chair or chair just
swing it off like it wasn't even matter
or a chair
god dammit he got me oh [ __ ] I need time
to the episode holy [ __ ] I could
favorite if you enjoyed and one more and
that's all for me now stay awesome bros
love you papa
[Music]